[Music]
in this week's vegas drives we take a
trip to the wild wild west las vegas
now's jillian lopez takes us to sandy
valley ranch located less than an hour
outside of las vegas
[Music]
well we have officially found a hidden
gem you guys might be surprised to learn
that just 45 minutes outside of las
vegas you can be a cowgirl or a cowboy
for a day we're here at sandy valley
ranch i can't wait to show you guys
around let's go check it out sitting on
160 acres of land sandy valley ranch
transports you back in time for 45
minutes and a hundred years in las vegas
that's marilyn googler born and raised
in las vegas she and her family wanted
to give people a place to ride horses
and sleep under the stars that's best
amenity is the stars because this sky
is just full you always can see the
milky way you guys have tiny homes
teepees wagons you can sleep over you
have a saloon you have a ranch house i
mean the list goes on and on yep
it's great it's a little move on at
first we have six accommodations on the
ranch all on airbnb during your stay you
can take part in cattle penny
enjoy meals from their ranch house you
are in the main ranch house at sandy
valley ranch and this room is used for
corporate events when corporate events
come
for weddings spreading receptions you
can see we have some of the tables set
up when weddings come in here
when the guests want to have breakfast
lunch or dinner then they will come in
here and have breakfast lunch or dinner
so it's open for the guests to come and
eat you can visit animals
and of course you can saddle up and jump
on a horse
you got the bandana i'm ready while
there are several trails and hour-long
rides available under the guidance of
trained cowboys today our horse ride is
leading us to the saloon well sandy
thanks for making me a cowgirl for a day
yes you are amazing i had the best time
be sure to come check out sandy valley
ranch there's so much to see and do here
like i said i don't think i'm ever
leaving but for now all we have to say
yeehaw
it's like a lot of fun i want to go
there that looks amazing
all right las vegas